sono francesca cavalieri e sono nata e
vissuta strada dell 11 ma come mai ci
parli di dove sei nata e vissuta ve ne
vado perché parli un pò triste li ha
sistemati
collimare le colline piacentine perché
l'impressione che nascono al mare questo
spesso a mio nonno possono fare il bagno
le persone che possono che i nostri
volontari hanno sono sciare e chi nasce
in collina che cosa può fare delle
colline recenti non hanno niente trust
le famose in realtà mi diceva le colline
piacentine sono magiche perché l in
pensiero sembra che il pensiero nel mais
perde tiene bloccate dalle montagne
invece fanno cacciare in colline si
allena ad andare oltre gli ostacoli e
con partendo dalle colline arriviamo non
si vede al video ma sono piuttosto alta
così a maggior parte delle persone
incontra mi chiedesse a giocare trova la
palestra oppure alla 1 ecco c'è qualcosa
che ci accomuna tutti questa domanda per
i più o meno tutti siamo sciolti
domandarci che cosa all'altra persona
che lavoro fa il degrado che cosa sa
fare
e quest'anno sarà la storia di me come
di giocatrice anche se io a pallate
destro ho giocato questa farà una storia
che riguarda proprio uno di voi sì sì tu
che stai guardando un video to coast e
ascoltarlo riguarda proprio il tè
riguarda te questo momento perché se
faccio una domanda e ti chiedo perché si
alza la mattina
questa domanda perché ti alzi una
mattina che cosa ti rende desideroso di
apprendere gli occhi di iniziare la
giornata
ecco madri
tante risposte questa domanda magari
potrebbe essere il pensiero di laurearmi
l'altro meraviglioso
c'è una certezza in questo che
anzi a schermatura dove prende di nota
la certezza che tutti ci fidiamo troppo
poco
ci chiediamo molto più spesso che cosa
mangiare per cena che tipo di scarpa a
mettere che cosa sapere investito
piuttosto che un altro ma troppo poco ci
chiediamo che cosa ci sveglia la mattina
e io voglio uccidere per un'altra volta
che cosa vi svela la mattina
so che molti di voi potrebbero
rispondere la sveglia d'accordo e ci
insegna la sveglia anche se molti di noi
si svegliano prima che la sveglia possa
suonare però mi chiedo se avete voglia
i minuti che rimangono alla fine del
tour di scendere un po più nel profondo
io sono un goccino nel profondo
voglio provare a farli diventare un po
più consapevoli di che cosa ti fa
svegliare la mattina
piuttosto che fare un grande una grande
spiegazione e raccontarvi come
filosofi psicologi una marea di altri
professionisti hanno interiorizzato su
che cosa ci piace fare chiamando la
ricerca del nostro potenziale del nostro
vero io
perché le storie stesso arrivo in più in
fretta e piu vicino quali di tutte le
fiori e quindi mi raccontano la mia
storia la storia riguardo io mi sono
domandato e ho capito perche mi sveglia
la mattina è iniziata un po lenta ma
veniamo sull'isola tutta la terra era
amici che al 1988 avevo circa 10 anni e
mia madre la trave in due centri non sa
chiamarli di informazione concessi in
cui si aiutano i ragazzi si fanno fatica
scolari sono stati bocciati in molte
volte lei dava lezioni di inglese anche
se sinceramente ho mai sentito la
probabile già numerosa a sostegno dei
ragazzi erano particolari difficoltà
ecco lei mi doveva attiviste di roma
giovane bambina mo prodigiosa dc
passerini dei magari partecipi io che
sono un bambino angosciata fermati per
in quel punto così libero sarà
assicurato sfida di cambiarli funzionari
vedere tutti questi ragazzi tristi e
arrabbiati
si hanno potuto definire falliti i
bocciati ecco io che la tormentata così
è noto che impostato tutto il pomeriggio
cinque gli armadietti dove di solito si
mettono i vestiti
che inizia sempre con la classica
domanda che era che cosa ti piace fare
che in realtà ho scoperto solo dopo
esser larghissima versione di che cosa
si sveglia la mattina e così un giorno
mi ricorda che sento ne fossimo mi sono
chiusa dentro questo armato ma chi al
richiamo con la luce strano che il tempo
passasse nelle masse momento di charlie
delta basket
era una ragazzo non mi ricordo mi pare
che si chiama stessa scheider archivio
di quello che potesse immaginare lo
sguardo arrabbiatissimo il cappuccio
della felpa sopra la testa sguardo kg un
po di brufoli la barba che iniziava a
crescerli sembrava veramente arrabbiato
io quando fra la domanda libro sopra
disputeranno interamente mi piace
assolutamente nulla mia madre quello che
vi fa la fatidica domanda che cosa e io
ho vinto
[Musica]
ho sentito quello che ho scoperto essere
motore di tutta la vita professionale ho
sentito quello che voglio sentire quello
che mi spaventa di più con il par a due
persone ho sentito silenzio
istituti sin qui non rispondeva io non
c'ero ho pensato invece niente pubblica
c'era niente l'unica scena niente vede
come un'esistenza senza fine
sono stata lì in quelle silenzio con gli
occhi di oggi riesco a vedere proprio
giudizio in quell odore di metallo in
quel caldo di silenzio a sentire un po
di farci dire con quella voce di diana
mi piace dietro diremo passa al sud
pederson sembra essere chiuso di una
credenza con una voce che non si capisce
parig rimando uomo e diceva ogni tanto
vado dati nonno e promo dare da mangiare
ma larini e ho sentito che quando ad
usarle fanno una voce quando di un'altra
e altre volte vogliono campare
l'armadio ho sentito come ormai
allora ricoperte sul corpo sentito mi
piace qualcosa lui e lui stava lì mia
madre diceva delle domande sui canarini
io stavo lì ad ascoltare lui parlava di
pianali e scusate ma ho pensato quantità
e geniale mi piace la rendita
prendete nota nuovamente
ci sono due cose sicure di prendere nota
la prima è che noi non siamo sicuri di
sapere cosa ci piace fare perché se vi
guardate dentro se in questo momento di
rete che cosa mi piace fare non tutti lo
sappiano e a volte serve che qualcuno
cerchi pace lo faccio notare oppure che
noi stessi ci crediamo ci studiamo la
cantina squadre perché si sveglia la
mattina e la seconda la seconda è che
quando scopriamo che ci piace fare
qualcosa non sappiamo magari quello può
essere la nostra vita noi siamo abituati
a pensare di dover fare i commercialisti
bianchino lo psicologo di fi tutti
qualcosa e manca invece sappiamo
che ci piace fare che può essere il
nostro lavoro possiamo che quello che ci
piace non è obbligatorio fare qualcosa
che non ci piace eppure questo non è
così scontato e quindi io non gli ho
detto niente per questo sono molti anni
dopo ben tornato in mente fasciani è
tornato in mente quando ci sono
università
e quando poi sono sentita come lui ce
l'ha studiato per citare studiato
psicologia perché sembrava una
promettente interessate ai sentimenti
umani e mi sono sentita
non so se è capitato anche a voi come si
che più o meno nel nuovo giusto più o
meno studiavo la cosa che pensavo che
sarebbero servite ma sentivo che mise di
onde
imbrigliarsi e meno in modo che non
tenevano non sapevo più cosa sognare
ecco magari una sensazione di continuare
a girare nel vuoto senza sapere bene che
direzione prendere quella parte che
tenti chiamo buona fase di disillusione
smettiamo di sognare sono certi di dover
fare qualcosa di concreto
ecco ancora prendete una notte
nessuno inventa traduttori di canali
nesi da solo nessuno
inventa le cose se qualcuno non li di
cetona po l'idea che qualcuno gli dice
pro se qualcuno mi dice vai in quella
direzione
e così
quando testa quando erano iata quando
pensavo che ha redditi tufare la
psicologa che non volevo essere quella
scuola d'armi strati piazzando voi
quella che avesse chiesto l'interprete
questo sogno ma cosa contiene sia stato
quello oppure quella che vi immaginate
sulla poltrona e io non volevo essere
quello essere non è da lui un modulo
stessa pa usa e sportivi cedi alfani
alla mattina e ho incontrato una
proposta che mi ha detto si prova magari
vai a vedere ci sono altri modi che mi
ha dato una direzione quindi il punto
importante che sia noi possiamo aver
bisogno possiamo chiedere aiuto ad aver
bisogno che qualcuno ci tiene e quando
siamo dall'altra parte dobbiamo dire
alle persone più giorni alle persone che
seguiamo
prova ispirarle verso qualcosa che
motiva dire trova sono con te vai a
vedere e così è successa meglio qualcuno
mi ha detto proprio a viaggiare su
centomila modi di fare lo psicologo da
ciascuno che su quel qualcosa e da
ciascuno per poi qualcosa che mi ha
fatto diventare
qualcuno
che la mattina si sveglia perché mi
piace quello che fa quindi non faccio
nulla di speciale in questo video non me
ne voglia di raccontare che cosa faccio
è una sintesi io faccio una cosa che mi
piace fare che non so se mi lascerà
domani ma so che considerano a
domandarmelo mattina via ciliani di fare
qualcosa di non far fare alla mattina
ecco pensavate che frustra della
conclusione
dalla conclusione di steppa anche a voi
fare qualcosa ha rispettato i lumini
dove
ieri ieri come ogni volta che faccio
questo tour a digita chiunque traduttore
di camerinese digitato in italiano e lo
dici da funghi e non è uscito nulla
questo significa che se da qualche parte
in qualche momento saggi non sto
ascoltando quale chiedere scusa a
formare gli ha detto proci perché è
l'anno e ne ordina e questo per dire che
tutti voi oggi stesso potete dirà
qualcuno prova o potete dire agli stessi
di provarci ma vi lascio con l'ultima
domanda perché sapeva mattina